Un usuario de YouTube
me mandó un problema que está muy interesante,
así que es el problema
que voy a resolver en este vídeo.
Este problema dice lo siguiente,
dice,
sabemos que "f" de "g" de "x",
es igual,
a dos veces la raíz cuadrada,
de "x" cuadrada más 1 menos 1,
entre...
entre la raíz cuadrada
de "x" cuadrada más 1, más 1
y también sabemos que "f" de "x",
es igual a "2x" menos 1,
dividido entre "x" más 1.
Ok, entonces la pregunta es
sabiendo que "f" de "g" de "x" es esta expresión
que se ve complicadísima,
y que "f" de "x" es igual a "2x" menos 1
entre "x" más 1
¿cuál es el valor?
¿cuál es el valor de "g" de "x"?
queremos determinar,
cuánto vale "g" de "x".
¡muy bien!
Pues este problema resulta que podemos hacerlo
a simple vista,
¿cómo le hacemos?
Pues lo primero que voy a hacer es
calcular "f" de "g" de "x",
sin saber quiénes "g" de "x",
simplemente usando la definición de "f"...
déjame hacerlo aquí abajo...
Es decir,
voy a ver quién es "f" de "g" de "x",
usando esta definición, la de "f",
entonces qué tenemos que hacer
donde aparezca "x",
debemos de poner la expresión
"g" de "x",
eso es lo que se hace cuando evaluamos una función,
¿verdad?
entonces nos quedaría
2 por "g" de "x"...
2 por "g" de "x",
menos 1,
dividido...
dividido entre "g" de "x"...
"g" de "x"...
más 1,
¡muy bien!
pero además,
sabemos que "f" de "g" de "x",
es igual a esta expresión que está aquí arriba,
es decir,
esto es igual a "2 por" raíz...
raíz...
de "x" cuadrada más 1 menos 1,
entre,
raíz de "x" cuadrada más 1
más 1.
Y a partir de aquí,
pues únicamente debemos identificar el patrón,
observa,
aquí tenemos 2 veces esta función "g"
menos 1
y aquí estamos dividiendo entre
g de "x" más 1,
y aquí es la misma idea con
raíz de x cuadrada más 1,
esta expresión,
aparece aquí y aparece acá.
Y de esta forma,
podemos obtener que "g" de "x"
es igual a la raíz cuadrada...
la raíz cuadrada,
de "x" cuadrada más 1.
Muy bien, entonces esta es una forma de hacerlo,
así a simple vista,
encontramos cuál es la función que sirve,
pero de hecho el ejemplo que me mandaron,
hasta viene con opciones.
Así que otra forma de resolver este problema,
teniendo estas opciones,
es sustituyéndolas en "f" de "x",
para ver cuál de las opciones,
nos da "f" de "g" de "x",
según propone el problema.
Vamos a hacer eso,
claro, o sea,
antes lo hice de esta forma para que vieras
que se puede hacer incluso sin tener las opciones,
pero vamos a hacerlo con las opciones,
para ver cómo podríamos hacerlo de una forma
un poco más fácil.
Entonces las opciones,
las opciones que nos da el problema,
es que "g" de "x" puede ser a...
puede ser raíz de x,
o puede ser,
raíz de x cuadrada más 1...
cuadrada más 1,
o puede ser la función "x",
o la función...
aquí debería ponerle "d"
o la función "x" cuadrada,
o la función "x" cuadrada más 1
"x" cuadrada más 1.
Ahora,
ya sabemos que la opción correcta es la opción b,
pero vamos a ver qué sucede
cuando sustituimos las otras opciones.
Si ponemos raíz de "x",
si "g" de "x" fuera igual a raíz de "x",
entonces "f" de "g" de "x"
sería dos veces raíz de "x"...
dos veces raíz de x menos 1,
dividido...
dividido entre raíz de "x" más 1
entonces obtendríamos,
pues esta expresión
y esta expresión no es la misma
que la que queremos,
esta no es "f" de "g" de "x"
como nos lo pide el problema,
entonces esta opción no es.
La opción "b" si sabemos qué es,
ahorita me la salto
si ponemos aquí
que "g" de  "x" es igual a "x",
entonces cuando componemos "f" con "g"
obtendríamos simplemente esta expresión, verdad,
obtendríamos "2x" menos 1
dividido entre "x" más 1
y esto no es la expresión que queremos.
De modo similar si le ponemos "x" al cuadrado,
obtendríamos,
"2x" cuadrada menos 1,
dividido entre "x" cuadrada más uno,
que una vez más no es lo que queremos,
y finalmente,
si ponemos "x" cuadrada más 1,
obtendríamos "2x" cuadrada más 1,
menos 1,
dividido...
dividido
entre "x" cuadrada más 1,
más 1.
Entonces bueno, aquí podríamos simplificar un poco más pero incluso simplificando
no queda esta expresión que queremos.
De esta forma,
el único chance es que la opción sea "b"
y en efecto si ponemos,
"g" de  "x" igual a
raíz de "x" al cuadrado más 1,
justo obtenemos que "f" de "g" de "x",
es la expresión que queremos ¿vale?
entonces lo que hicimos primero es resolverlo a simple vista y ahorita lo resolvemos lo resolvimos
checando cada una de las opciones y la opción b es la correcta bueno espero que este vídeo te haya sido de ayuda
y sobre todo espero que le haya ayudado a este usuario que me mandó la pregunta nos vemos hasta la próxima